[موسيقى]
انا اسمي ريما دحبور مصممه ازياء من
الاردن
وعندي علامه التجاريه اللي اسمها ريما
دحبور
[موسيقى]
لما تم اختيار الفستان من المجموعه من
ما كنا بالضبط عارفين هو راح يكون الامين
او ايش هي المناسب اللي راح تنلبس فيه
الفستان
لمن حدا نفكر بالتراث او الاشي ثقافي
دائما بفكروا باشي من الماضي فاحنا حبينا
انه نجيبه لاشي لتصاميم معاصره بتناسب
الامراه
المعاطي لابسه الوطن العربي بغض النظر هي
من وين او بس تكون كتير فخوره بجذورها
وبثقافتها ودراسها
هذا كان من فساتين الكثير خاصه بالنسبه
لالي وحبيته كتير وكان من اصعب الفساتين
اللي عملناها بالذات لانها بتتميز
بالتطريز
الابيض على ابيض ما في كثير حرفيات
بالتطريز بيعرفوا
للتطريز اللي يكون شوي موضع
غير كتير متكلف لانه بلباسنا التراثي بكون
معروف انه
فكثير انبسطت لما اختاروا هذا الفستان
مميز جدا بامعاشته معمول بالكاف الحرير
اخد تقريبا ست اشهر من الشغل المتواصل
فيه يعني
كل طاقم من النساء اللي اللي يشتغلوا على
هذا الفستان كانوا مبدعين وكثير انا يعني
فخوره فيهم بانه احنا طلعنا هاي القطعه
كتير انبسطت لما جلاله الملكه رانيا حطت
لمستها الخاصه فيها على الفستان وانها حطت
البلت تبع فستان عرسها على الفستان طبعا
هاي كانت
لمستها الخاصه
في الوطن العربي للموضه يعني لمسه الملكه
رانيا كانت جدا مميزه اخذتها لبعد اخر
لمسه ام لبنتها ما حدا بيقدر انه يعملها
فورشور
[موسيقى]